everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm today we're going to be
starting a new series my most requested
video as of late is to do some deep
analysis of Kasparov vs. deep blue so if
you're not too familiar with deep blue
this is a supercomputer created back in
the 1990s by IBM up into this point
there was never a computer that actually
beat a reigning world champion in
competition computers at this point were
not that great at chess they could you
know do long calculations but as far as
a timed game they were not that great so
IBM came out there and said you know
we've created a supercomputer called
deep blue and we want to challenge
Kasparov now they did play twice in 1996
they played the first time Kasparov did
win that four to two by score four to
two and in 1997 they had a rematch and
deep blue actually won that three and a
half points to two and half points now
there was a lot of controversy Kasparov
basically said that IBM cheated
especially in in one particular match
that we'll be going over in this series
he requested a rematch for a third kind
of a rubber match kind of a
winner-takes-all best two out of three
IBM decided to decline that and
therefore we kind of have this you know
Kasparov won 1996 and you know IBM deep
blue won 1997 with some controversy in
there but a lot of fantastic games I
like to do a lot of analysis of famous
games I thought what better way to do
you know so many people were requested
but I think it's so fantastic to watch a
reigning world champion in his prime
Garry Kasparov one of the greatest chess
players of all time playing against a
supercomputer so you know obviously
computers they don't get fatigue you
can't really trick them you know they
definitely play one style which you know
humans kind of you know changed up every
now and then but again there's not
really many mistakes that the computer
does so you have to play tactically
sound you have to play great chess and
that's what I think we're going to be
seeing through all of these games so I'm
actually going to be going over four
different games from the 96 series and
three different games for
ninety-seven series all of which were
someone one so if you're like oh you
know why don't you show games where they
tied well there's some phenomenal games
where you know both sides tied but I
just don't want to do a series of like
you know 15 games but I am going to do
all seven of the games that actually
ended in someone winning so just if
you're thinking about some of the videos
that are coming up in the future still
going to be doing some openings but
definitely going to be focusing a lot on
this series right now so hopefully you
guys enjoy this without further ado
we'll go ahead and get into the game in
this game this is 1996 this is game
number one the white pieces are being
played by deep blue the supercomputer
from IBM and the black pieces are going
to be played by Kasparov the reigning
world champion at this given time so
white starts with pawn to e4 very very
common garrison Gary Kasparov is going
to start with pawn to c5 this is the
Sicilian offense and white plays pawn to
c3 now kind of studying over this game I
thought this was interesting a lot of
times the top level play you'll see you
know after pawn to e4 in the Sicilian
offense you might see you know Knight to
f3 if you want to
so pawn to c3 I was actually kind of
surprised but definitely interested to
see how this game would evolve with this
pawn to c3 just because you don't see it
that much at top level play Gary
Kasparov plays pawn to d5 again trying
to control the center of the board
trying to counter this pawn here on e4
likes really going to have a dominant
control of this d5 square early on into
the game you'll see that's kind of a
focus point that Gary Kasparov kind of
focuses on you know even moving into the
middle of the game so White's going to
take on d5 and Kasparov is going to come
down and take here on d5 now typically
in time you see the Queen come involved
early into the game you can usually get
your your Knights involved into the game
and actually kick that Queen back with
tempo but as you can see in this example
the pawn here on c3 is actually blocking
the knight to come to c3 so right now
white cannot kick this Queen off with
tempo so he's going to continue with his
development and just play pawn to d4
again pushing his pawns for trying to
control the center of the board and
Parvez going to do the same thing black
plays Knight to f6 again focusing on
simple development moves from as minor
pieces but also again trying to hone
down on this d5 square he's really going
to focus on that early on to the game
white plays Knight to f3 again he can't
get his Queens Knight involved to the
game so go ahead and get your other
Knight involved into the game and cause
problems going to go ahead and bring his
Bishop down to g4 now it's very
important early on if you watch me in my
videos you know that it's a usually a
lot easier to get your King Bishop
involved into the game so the light
square bishop for white and also the
dark square bishop for black here so you
know many times it's harder to get the
Queen Bishop involved into the game so
anytime you can get this out and pin
down one of your opponent's knights
typically that is not a bad thing at all
so kind of restricts the play for white
here as far as you know you really can't
get this tight involved into the game
yet he's really going to need to use
this Bishop to defend this and he does
get this light square Bishop involved
into the game he doesn't kinda have to
worry about that later on you know he is
at some point gonna want to play you
know pawn to e6 come as we talked about
before you know opening up this dark
square so he can kind of defend this
pawn here on c5 also kind of get
involved into the action of the board if
he wants to focus in on try to attack
this pawn on f2 always a huge weakness
for white early on so definitely you
want to get these bishop out of you know
this back row before you start to you
know solidify your pawn structure and
kind of lock that Bishop in so that's
kind of why we see this Bishop come out
early and why it's going to play Bishop
to e2 again as we talked about making
sure that this pin is no longer there to
the Queen so y can kind of freely do
what he wants to from here on out black
is now going to play pawn to e6 again
now that we have the Bishop outside of
the pawn chain garry kasparov can now
play pawn to e6 getting ready to get his
dark squared bishop involved into the
game now White's going to play pawn to
h3 you never really want to have you
know a bishop here kind of pinning down
one of your pieces you really want to
kind of alleviate some of that pressure
so pawn to h3 very logical move trying
to kick that back typically a top-level
play even though a knight and a
bishop are around the same point value
typically you won't see someone trade
that off early on as far as giving up a
bishop for a knight it's much easier to
open up a game as far as removing some
of the pawn structures in the middle and
bishops do really really well in open
games it's much harder to close the game
up as far as the pawn structure you
can't really move around the middle of
the board
I mean Knights do fairly well in in
those closed games so that's kind of why
if you're always wondering like why
don't people actually like to trade off
the bishops early on that's kind of why
later on once you see the pawn
structures kind of get fixed as far as
you kind of know what's going to happen
then actually you know a lot of people
will prefer you know maybe Knights over
bishops but early on
you typically rarely see that from a
high level chess player especially you
know Garrick espavo of the reigning
world champion so I black Singh will go
ahead and kick that back to h5 and
White's going to castle on the kingside
obviously you know once you start to
develop your minor pieces then you
definitely want to get your your King to
safety if it's castling on the Queen
side or if it's castling on the King
side excuse me a queen or king side you
definitely want to get him to safety now
you're typically going to be castling on
the side that you are developing your
minor pieces so if you look at this case
you know white has developed his Knight
to f3 he's also developed his Bishop to
e2 so obviously more than likely he's
going to castle on the King side black's
going to continue his development knight
to c6 again putting a lot of pressure on
this square here on the 4 again he's
pretty much dominating this square here
on d5 I does have this pawn and this
night here on f6 both kind of eyeing
down an e already has a major piece
right there on d5 with his Queen so
already has this and again starting to
you know get the rest of his pieces
evolved into the game right now it's
about equal in you know if you're kind
of looking if you run this through a
search an engine for chess
whether it's Fritz or Rip Curl you know
whatever you're running as far as the
positions about equal right now we'll
kind of get into you know later on as
far as when that starts to change but
right now it it's pretty close to equal
right now is going to bring his Bishop
to e3 again early on both sides are just
trying to you know get their King to
safety and develop their pieces in a
logical manner right now so black is
going to take here on d4 and why it's
going to take with this pawn on d5 and
then we see the bishop immediately come
down to B for now it's very important to
note anytime a piece or a pawn moves
from your opponent always look at the
space left behind you may have heard
this from a lot of other you know great
chess minds it's always thinking about
the the space left behind once this pawn
moves from c3 to d4 it kind of opens up
this space here on b4 and garry kasparov
immediately he needs to get his dark
square bishop involved into the game so
he can castle on the King side so he
goes ahead and brings down his Bishop to
b4 obviously it's kind of a passive move
to bring it to d6 there's no really need
to bring it to e7 his Knights not being
pinned down to anything obviously c5
would be a huge blunder a3 you might as
well just turn off the video right now
so b4 a very logical move and also you
know it kind of restricts some of the
play you know a lot of times you might
see white bring his you know rook to e1
kind of restricting that so definitely a
good move from Kasparov white decides
now to kind of kick this back so he
plays pawn to a3 very similar to what he
did over here with pawn to h3 the
bishops gonna come back to a5 and now
why it's going to play Knight to c3
again developing his minor pieces
getting him involved into the game he
knows well we say he it's a computer but
you know again Geragos barb is not going
to give up his bishop early on it to the
game to exchange this so he can it now
as we talked about before he wasn't able
to but the computer was not able to
develop his minor piece this knight here
and kick this Queen back with tempo but
he is now so that's kind of why he has
taken this opportunity now and the
Queen's going to come back to d6 and now
White's going to play Knight to b5 again
continuing this assault putting a lot of
pressure on Garry Kasparov and now
garrix Bob needs to continue
to move his queen because it's being
attacked so he brings it back to even
and now the computer plays Knight to e5
and this is kind of where I want to stop
and kind of talk about both of the
positions as both positions kind of now
we got we go into the middle game so
we're going to go ahead and go over a
few more moves you can see there is a
discovered attack on the ship disappear
on h5 go so Garry Kasparov is going to
go ahead and just exchange these bishops
here on e to his bishop here on h5 was
not doing a whole heck of a lot and
since this night here on e5 is no longer
being pin might as well just go ahead
and exchange this since the LightSquared
bishop for white again early on is a
little bit stronger than the
light-square bishop for black so might
as well just come in and exchange though
so White's going to go ahead and take
that and then Black's going to castle on
the King side so this is where I want to
kind of talk about the transition
everyone you know there's three main
parts of a chess game you do have the
the opening kind of the beginning then
you kind of have the middle game which
is where we're kind of about to to get
into and then you have the end game
which we'll get into a little bit later
but the middle game is kind of reached
when both sides have developed pretty
much all their pieces you know you
obviously develop your minor pieces
towards the middle of the board minor
pieces typically are supporting your
pawns are supporting other minor pieces
trying to control the center you
definitely want to have you know King
safety whether that's on the King side
or the Queen side you always want to
connect your rooks rooks are always
working better if they are connected
whether they are on you know the first
rank or if they're on a specific file
like the C file if they're both on the C
file they definitely work well if
they're connected in that sense but from
here both sides are developed they've
done everything to have King safety so
what do they do now and that's kind of
where we get into just the heart of
chess and and this is where I really
enjoy studying the game because you
really now have to have some sort of
strategy you have to you know really dig
deep and start to find different tactic
and have all your pieces start to work
together your major pieces start to
defend and help out your minor pieces as
they begin to actually attack and not
just support their pawns so a lot starts
to go into it so if we kind of look at
if we look at this position right here
white is a little bit more active
obviously he does have you know his
knights here on the fifth rank Black has
a little bit back he's only on the third
rank if we kind of look at it from his
angle white does have this pawn here on
F for controlling the certain of the
board a little bit more here on them
this pawn here on e6 but do keep in mind
that this pawn here on d4 is an isolated
pawn meaning that there are no pawns on
either side of it so this can be a huge
weakness it can also be a huge strength
it's going to be a little bit easier for
this to become a passed pawn getting
past this pawn here on e6 then it can
freely come over here to d8 and promote
to any piece that white wants it but
right now it's actually going to be a
huge weakness that garry kasparov is
actually going to hone in on and try to
exploit this pawn here on d4 so just
keep that in mind you know white does
have a little bit of an advantage as far
as you know his tempo his you know
middle of the board is a little bit more
advanced to that but garry kasparov
definitely has ways that he can attack
and kind of chip away at this position
right here that white has now we've kind
of talked about how rooks work together
you also want to have rooks on open file
so immediately in this game you're going
to see white bring his rook to c1 you
know obviously he can do a lot more
damage this rook can if he's on the open
file than if he's kind of behind this
pawn here on a3 he can't really do a lot
so it this kind of goes for any of your
pieces which are why bishops are good in
open games the more space they can move
to the the more squares they can
actually get to I'm in a fast period of
time the better they are so Knights
actually work better in the middle of
the board because they can you know get
to all different places of the board if
they're on the edge if they're on the
rim a lot of times you'll hear the
knight on the rim is dim the knight
can't go
that many places so anytime you're
looking at a piece and you're like where
would this be good on the board look at
the board and see where you can go that
gives it the most opportunity to move
now in the case of a rook it's always
going to be on open file so this rook
automatically comes to c1 and garry
kasparov immediately brings his rook to
c8 this is an open file in C file so
they both kind of flock to that now the
bishop is going to come to g5 logic
moves we talked about before anytime you
can pin down a knight to your opponent's
Queen here obviously this Knight is also
protecting this d5 square always
important square the sooner the board
it's a good thing now it doesn't have to
worry too much about this night here on
e5 he does have a pawn in the Queen
protecting it but he does need to notice
that computer being a he is that this
pawn is no longer being protected by
this bishop so Garak is Favre right away
is going to start to attack this again
it is an isolated pawn right now it is a
weakness for white so garry kasparov
sees this and he's going to start to
attack that he brings his Bishop to b6
logical move there's not a whole lot of
different things that spark can do right
now so black moves Bishop to b6
attacking this pawn and White's going to
play you know hey Bishop takes on f6 now
York's barb is actually going to take
with this pawn here now if you look at
you say you know why doesn't he take
with his queen if he takes with this you
know as pawn he does have this G file
open and that's true but keep in mind if
he does take with this Queen it's
actually going to be a pretty tough game
for him when white plays Knight to d6
it's kind of getting too close for
comfort here and this Queens kind of at
a position here you know the Queen side
is being attacked
you know heavily from white here and
it's just not quite as you know as good
as if he just takes with with g6 and
again he can always you know bring his
King over to h8 if he needs to for
safety um he can also when he brings his
King over to h8 he can also get a rook
involved into the game if he wants to
put a lot of pressure on this King side
from white so if you look at that and
you're like you know why is he do that
it's
she not that bad of a move again it is
also forcing this night to move so the
night's being attacked he needs to come
back to to see four and then blacks
going to play look to d8 again this is a
semi-open file so you definitely want
your rooks on semi open files or open
files and it's also putting more and
more pressure on this pawn on d4 so
always don't just move to move your
pieces take a look at Gary Kasparov deep
blue supercomputer move for a reason so
right now Gary Kasparov has one mission
and that is to attack this pawn on d4
and that's a good mission you know white
is trying to basically create small
little weaknesses across the board and
you kind of see that from you know his
exchange here on f6 and also this next
move so he plays Knight to b6 and blacks
going to retake with his pawn here on b6
so you know as we kind of talked about
moving into the middle game there's
always these small things that kind of
add up into a game that at the end kind
of become much bigger things as you can
see white has exploited and now black
has two double pawns so he has a double
pawn here on the F file and he also has
a double pawn here on the B file so
definitely a huge weakness for Gary
Kasparov obviously nothing that you know
he can't play back from and you know
white still has this huge weakness here
with a isolated pawn on the D file why
is now going to bring his other rook
involved into the game obviously he
wants to protect this pawn here on d4
and garrix Bob is going to play pawn to
f5 now this is really just getting ready
for his Queen to come to f6 to add more
pressure on to the pawn on d4 he also
kind of wants to solidify this pawn
chain this pawn here on f6 is only being
defended by the Queen but when it does
come to f5 it does have that extra
support from the pawn here on e6 so kind
of you know a versatile move as far as
what he can do with that but that that's
kind of why he did it so from here
excuse me why it's going to play Queen
to e3
again getting ready if he wants to he
can now not only protect this pawn here
on d4 but you can also get involved into
the game you can come to g550 you want
to obviously that would be moronic right
now because of the Queen there on e7 he
can also come to g3 check the King so
this definitely gives him a lot of
flexibility and that's kind of why you
move Queen to e3 now black is now going
to play Queen to f6 as we talked about
again putting a lot of pressure on this
pawn on d4 white now since is that
there's too much pressure on this pawn
just here on d4 he actually decides to
push forward with his pawn now Garrick
sparf now decides to exchange rooks off
so rook exchange rook exchange and
Garrick respond with this pawn on d4 now
if you kind of look at this exchange you
kind of see these small little things
adding up and adding up and even if you
run it through a chess engine again I
always like to look at different
positions in the game and just see how
you know supercomputers now which are
obviously a lot stronger than you know
even deep blue was but just to kind of
see and there's these small little
increments that kind of go on these
small different moves throughout the
game and at the end of the game you know
they definitely add up so as you can see
here garry kasparov has doubled pawns on
the F file he has doubled pawns on the B
file and he now has an isolated pawn on
the D file so definitely starting to you
know get more and more weaknesses for
black where white he got he kind of got
rid of his one weakness which was that
isolated pawn on the D file and he kind
of exchanged that for an isolated pawn
you know for black here so just keep
that in mind hit white is down the
material right now but he you know he's
going to get that back pretty soon he
can always take with his Queen here on
b6 first though he is going to play pawn
to b3
you know his pawn was being you know
attacked by the Queen here on f6 so he
knows there's no way really to protect
this pawn on b3 safely obviously he
could move his knight but it's not going
to be
safe because the route could always come
here to c8 if you wanted to so just keep
that in mind
from here blacks going to play King to
h8 definitely just the threat sometimes
even if a player doesn't move just the
threat of the Queen coming to let's see
g3 you know attacking this long diagonal
or once the Queen moves from f6 even
just coming to g5 the threat of that
sometimes can you know be very very you
know intense so here black decides to
bring is king over to h8 now white can
now come safely to b6 and take this pawn
here on b6 Derrick's farm is now going
to start to push forward he's going to
play rook to g8 starting to put a lot of
pressure on the Kings side from white
now Gary Kasparov was playing a mediocre
player that falls for traps white might
actually play Queen takes on b7 again it
is free material why not take it you you
know you're already up as far as you
know pawn structure why not be up an
extra pawn and material well this would
actually be a huge blunder gierek's Bob
could out come to g5 threatening
checkmate here on g2 if white plays you
know pawn to g2 gierek's Bob can now
come down and take this rook here on c1
unfortunately for Garry Kasparov he's
playing a supercomputer and
supercomputers do not fall for mind
tricks at least in game 1
they don't fall for mind trick so from
here White's going to play Queen to c5
again still putting a lot of pressure on
black so attacking this pawn here on d5
again critical square we've talked about
all game long but also defending the
rook here on c1 very very important that
this rook is supported now Gary Kasparov
plays a huge mistake and he plays pawn
to d4 now if we look at this before he
starts to push forward he actually needs
to get you know kind of a defense he's
kind of brought his rook over to g8 that
kind of failed you know there's really
not going to be a huge attack that he
can do that's going to work because if
now it with the
here on c5 here to bring his queen - you
know g5 really wouldn't matter now if
the pawn came to g2 or excuse me g3
because this is kind of a fail he would
you know just take the rook and then
lose his Queen here so what do you
really need to do in this situation is
just bring his rook over to d8 you know
he's still down as far as you know if
you run this through analysis but he
definitely is still going to have a much
better game here you definitely want
your rooks if they're not on open files
you want them supporting passed pawns
you want to push those pawns you know as
fast and aggressive as you can but
instead he kind of pushes it with no
support so he plays pawn to d4 and now
White's going to play Knight to d6 kind
of getting in the grille of Gary
Kasparov it's going to be really hard to
handle this night here on the six that's
attacking so many different squares you
know again it's just going to be really
hard so Garak Bob now plays pawn to f4
another movie could have played instead
of rook over to d8 could have played f4
first now why it's going to play pawn
excuse me Knight takes on b7 again
blacks now losing material it's not
looking quite that great and now Garrick
sparf plays Knight to e5 and White's
going to continue with Queen over to d5
again still putting a lot of pressure
now pressuring on this f7 squared as
well and garrix far off now is going to
play pawn to f3 he's kind of trying you
know obviously you can't take with his
pawn here on f3 obviously again if you
know white fell for traps he could
always take on you know d4 gaining
material but this would be a huge
blunder just with a rook coming down
here to g2 why it's actually in a huge
you know hole right here but it is a
supercomputer again they don't make
mistakes so white all he has to do is
just play pawn to g3 and then Gary
Kasparov plays Knight to d3 and the
rooks going to come over here to c7 he
is being attacked so
does need to move this rook and white
comes to c7 anytime you can get your
rook to the seventh rank if you're white
or the second ring for black that's
exactly where you want it to be
obviously you're going to be able to
attack all of the pawns that have not
moved yet
and also if the King is not moved it
pretty much restricts all of his
movement on on the board now if there's
no pawns on the seventh rank and the
King is outside of the eighth rank it's
not quite as good but still definitely
if you're kind of looking to move your
rook forward kind of looking for a place
for him to go the seventh rank is
usually a very very good place for him
to go
so from here Derek's problem probably
makes another blunder that kind of cost
him the game from here you know he
probably could have come to let's say
Queen to e5 this is probably his best
bet try to exchange off these Queens
here and then just try for you know it's
high he's definitely down in material
right now but if he played smart he
probably could have gotten a tie in my
opinion instead he brings his rook over
to be eight and this is kind of kind of
the end right here so the knight now
comes to d6 attacking this rook here on
e8 Garrick Apsara was just kind of going
for the win he he brings his rook now
down to e1 unfortunately there's just
not enough pieces to get into this
attack and the king is going to be very
very safe he's just going to come over
to h2 the Knights going to come into f2
gierek's Bob kind of sees that his
really only opportunity is to attack
later on if he wants to bring his rook
over to h1 you know he can do that but
again his time is too limited right now
the Knights now going to come to f7
check so the King has to move here the
King is going to come down to g7 kind of
continue to go through the moves Knight
comes down to g5 check discovered attack
of the rook is now attacking check the
King's going to come back to h6 and now
the rook comes over to h7 and this is
actually where Garry Kasparov resigned
in the game so
you know good game the first game goes
to white the supercomputer this is
actually the first time a supercomputer
beat a reigning world champion so a
definitely definitely huge event now you
know fear not 1996 garrix Favre actually
did win a series so spoiler alert if
you're getting ready for the future
videos garrix prob definitely comes back
with a vengeance and just dominates but
in this particular game I don't know if
he was caught off guard or just didn't
sleep enough the night before but you
know white definitely played a very very
sharp game definitely found small little
mistakes from gierek swab that he could
kind of you know go after an attack and
at the end of it
garrix Parv is in a bad position as king
is being attacked now just to go ahead
and play it out cuz I was like oh you
know I don't he's not in checkmate so
why would he give up it's definitely
gonna be hard for him to continue
obviously you know he can bring his king
to g6 if you want to now the Queen can
come to g8 check not a whole lot of
moves that can come from here King can
come back to f5 you know now the knight
can take on f3 and this kind of stops
you know rook was black was really
looking to bring his rook over to h1 for
checkmate but without this pawn here on
f3 it's not going to do a whole heck of
a lot so even if the rook comes over to
h1 after the King comes to g2 there's
not a whole lot the black can do here
obviously he can bring his king over
here trying to eye down you know his
queen coming to f3 for checkmate but you
know white can always just bring his
rook down to h4 pretty much anything
black board a try why it has an answer
is Kings in the middle the board never a
good sign when your opponent has you
know queen and a rook involved into the
game so Gary Kasparov just went ahead
and you know resigned in this situation
so definitely learned a lot study in
this game hopefully you guys enjoyed a
lot not only watching garrix part of one
of the great players watching a tactical
supercomputer play chess but also just
watching you know a chess game deeply
analyzed if you guys enjoyed it let me
know in the comments I
we're going to be doing a series so
there's going to be about seven videos
about this so definitely hopefully you
guys watch this and enjoy it
and I will see you guys in the next
video
thanks for watching